if you missed the line in the game you
reset you miss it on the track
you could die
hello everyone I'm Jacqueline Coley here
with the cast and filmmakers of Gran
Turismo for our big ticket interview
welcome everyone now I'm going to start
with you for this one because I know
that you made an intense sort of vision
as far as like not only making sure you
put these actors in the car but you also
had these IMAX cameras so talk about how
you really wanted to again put us in the
seat of F1 racing IMAX actually doesn't
there's very few films are made with
IMAX cameras anymore because they're
organic negative film Celluloid camera
so we use digital cameras that had IMAX
certified
um chips in them so we just we just kind
of made sure that all of the footage
that we got was was iMac certified and
able to be in in giant theaters so it's
a resolution thing
um and it you know the approach was for
everything to be as real as possible and
then rely on VFX if we needed to later
but try to do everything in camera so
the film really has like a sort of an
old school filmmaking approach where
it's incredibly production heavy and
moving lots of race cars to different
race tracks and then having the actors
like Archie inside the torture chamber
known as the car
and yeah it's just a very visceral real
feeling so hopefully on an iMac screen
it's going to be you know intense and
and you can really feel like it was made
with real cars and real real people I do
love that and Archie I'm going to start
with you because that's the video games
are the ultimate bit of wish fulfillment
but you are really taking that to the
next level where you have this real life
story that this is based on where this
guy goes from playing the video game to
being in the car seat talk about what
that was like for you because I know it
was a very intense training process to
get prepared for as Neil said it was a
visceral and real uh a lot realer than I
I think I anticipated
um I remember like day one the safety
guy coming and being like the things we
are attempting in I've never been
attempted before in cinema and I was
looking at Nila really bro
it works I mean it was intense I there's
a reason these guys are some of the best
athletes in the world because it is one
of the most taxing things I've ever done
I mean I was throwing up pretty much on
a daily basis the g-force all of that
stuff that you see there's nothing every
shot you see of me in the car is me in
the car we didn't cheat there's no wind
machine blowing me to make it look like
I'm like we're moving there's no static
movements I'm in the car going racing
speed and there's kind of just nothing
to prepare you for that unless you're
built that way we learned pretty quickly
that I'm not and I am I am an actor
Archie is also really tall so there were
issues we had to like remove the seat
between the Stunt Driver and then Archie
to make sure you can fit in six foot
five so those Le Mans starts you know
I'm Nimble that is uh that's one lucky
thing but it was it was an incredible
experience to do something that you know
I clearly at my size was never built
designed to do and to be with some of
the best people in the industry doing it
it was you know next form is a rocky
horse racing yeah
I will add any awesome
Family Fair because one of your stunt
drivers was actually yawn correctly he
was on set like that is so crazy I mean
has ever been I don't know if that's
ever been done before with someone like
they're making about someone and the
real person yeah before it was amazing I
mean it was one amazing
to have him do the driving which kind of
was a beaut like a beautiful accident he
we were just bringing Jan into I think
maybe just for one scene and and he was
so brilliant at it I mean it's one thing
to be an incredible driver but then to
be able to hit marks and and drive in
that kind of way is a separate skill and
he was so good at both that he ended up
just laying for the rest of the rest of
the shoot but it was such an
unbelievably incredible tool for us
because yama's on set as a pool of
information so we improvised so many
scenes and so if you know there was
something very specific about Jan's life
that I needed to improvise around he was
there the entire time I could he could
feel me drips of information things that
I remember having a conversation with
Yan about the the setup in his room that
he initially qualified on for GT Academy
was it set that he built in DT class in
a woodwork class himself and I remember
saying that to Neil like dude how crazy
is that he was like what me and Neil
were like getting what I mean I'm a
chatting so much I was like yeah you
didn't know that and so we had that
built then for for the film in his
bedroom is the exact replica of the one
that he made himself in Woodward class
it was like things like that he was just
there as a constant resource it was
amazing Orlando I do have to bring it to
you because big budget action and genre
filmmaking is nothing new to you but
this is a different type of that film so
you know I had an initial conversation
with Neil and um I'm a huge fan anyway
um from back in the day and we have we
have uh friends in common like Peter
Jackson so we discussed um his vision
for the movie which was just really
exciting to me because Neil's got this
obviously epic kind of huge scale of the
way he approaches making films and he
and he had this vision for taking that
all kind of narrowing all that on into
into what is a real true life story but
with this
you know with driving scenes that will
kind of blow your mind so it's something
you want to see on a big screen right
because it's like it's a but we have
this title you know Gran Turismo I'm not
a gamer but I appreciate graduate
smokers it's like one of the biggest
titles out there but within that tile
you've got the story of
um my character Danny comes up with this
idea Danny is actually based on Dan Cox
who was a marketing manager for Nissan
and went to Sony and came up with this
idea of putting kids and ultimately
um Archie's character Yan takes the
podium at the end of the day and well it
doesn't take the whole Podium but it
gets on on the podium after Le Mans
because he he was so good he won this GT
Academy that Danny came up with this
idea to like we're going to take kids
from it's a dream right it's a dreamer's
movie it's like Danny had this dream of
putting kids in cars onto tracks and and
he had a dream of doing it you know and
he won and so it's it that that to me
was like something I think kids can get
into and you know it's a movie that I
think people will you know if you love
race cars and driving then this is that
any Podium within months as well I
should say as well how many months was
it like years later how many months
because I keep wanting to I think it was
over 12 months yeah it was quite which
is insane to look never had any like
real car experience and race car
experience and then know that the I mean
but he passed his driving test like
maybe a couple of weeks before he drove
before he drove to take this to enter
GTA Academy it was crazy he had barely
been in a car and then within 12 months
Gran Turismo prepared him for that but
it shows you how how accurate the tracks
are you know and how accurate the
Dynamics of the cars are that he could
he could make that switch Yeah I do love
that and then bringing you along ma'am
you can tell us all about
like another
lady what it's really like but if I
can't talk to you intensely about the
Spice Girls please tell us how much
wisdom you were able to sort it impart
as far as someone who's been right there
on the race car like on the tracks way
closer than any of us could because of
your incredible partner well I've always
loved cars my father was the second hand
car dealer and yeah and so I was always
taken to like racing and so I've always
had that love for it
and then you know being backstage and
looking at how F1 happens will blow your
mind it's so you really respect them as
athletes it's a team sport they really
have to work together it's not just to
drive around the track you appreciate
that and then but the other thing is
it's dangerous it's really dangerous and
you know what I love about this movie is
that and as a director he really
embodies you know okay it's an action
movie but it's more than that it's an
unairbrushed action movie you feel it
you you really feel the pulse of it you
know through your creativity I think
it's what is brilliant you really get a
taste of it and
um and the acting is real I think that's
really sort of elevated to a modern day
action film it really does I will have
to ask this just a little bit slightly
you've been around this for a lot longer
have you felt the rise in recent years
both with folks in F1 because I would
feel it's getting crazy this is nothing
compared to the crowds you've seen in
your time but it's getting like insane
in a lot of ways it's a drive to
survivors yeah I think so I always
describe it as the Kardashians on Wheels
yeah
I don't fall in love with personalities
you know so you learn about yeah it is
that you've got all these amazing
personalities these you know very good
good looking drivers these team
principles you know all that you know at
each other and then also you can
appreciate that from a technical side
and start appreciating that there's so
much more to it so there's a it's a
great entry point and then when you
start to um unpeel it then you go wow
yeah so have you been to a race before
yeah I was just I was just about to say
actually when we were doing when we were
doing um prep for Gran Turismo like
films films are very
um they're very logistically heavy right
as as Productions and so I I sort of
when I think of logistics I think of
filmmaking because it's my experience
but we were we shot this in Hungary at
the Hungarian ring a lot of the film was
shot there and it's a Formula One Track
so as we were in prep F1 at Hungary was
there and I could see the scale of it
and it was like you know it was like a
hundred times the size of of a film and
then and then they also go to tracks all
over the world right and I was I was
struck with the level of logistics
around that as a sport must I mean it
probably must be the most logistically
heavy thing I think on the globe yeah
it's really impressive I again I really
again I'm maybe of a fan of the more of
maybe the drivers let's be honest I
really enjoy their their tick tocks uh
but there's also folks that are huge
fans and like myself of the video game
Gran Turismo there's going to be folks
that are going to be just a fan of all
of your talents here how did you
approach that as a filmmaker to make
sure you brought in the racing fans
gaming fans maybe some of the girls that
just like the way the driver's suit up
you know how did you how did you bring
it's all in here for this one actually I
was in a test screening in Dallas where
Orlando changes it showed in the car and
a lot of girls were like quite stoked
about that it was like audible in the
theater which is hilarious but that's
one of the only times yeah it was one of
the only times but
[Laughter]
um no I mean the way that I I think that
any film is just going to live or die
whether or not it's emotional skeleton
is strong right like if you don't have
that you don't really have a film yeah
and there was there was um I think if
people see this movie watching Gran
Turismo they're going to be surprised by
the level of emotion in the movie it's
much more emotional than you would
expect for a video game film for a film
about racing it's way way way more
emotional and then it's also a true
story which I think probably amplifies
that to some degree so
um from my way into it was an emotional
story and then just try to make it I I
wanted it incredibly unvarnished like no
as limited visual X as possible
everything is real as possible and it's
sort of I think the end result does feel
that way it feels like just um
I mean it's much cleaner than the other
films that I've made just because I
default to you know more dystopian kind
of imagery but it still does feel very
real I really do appreciate this is like
that this is such a shiny little lovely
family movie that you've done I'm like I
was like if you would have asked me back
then maybe but I love that this is a the
next progression Archie have to ask you
sir as someone who's played video games
there's such a huge video game like
Renaissance happening right now we've
had the better entries sort of like we
finally figured it out do you feel like
well first of all what was your history
with it did you play it as the game are
you a heavy gamer or was this some sort
of like more of the Deep dive into it
the true answer is no I uh I didn't I
didn't play games growing up that was
not my experience but I was talking
about this a minute ago and one I think
the incredible and the fun thing about
our job is diving head first into these
worlds and these communities that we
didn't like we didn't have access to
when we were younger I had access to
games I've just got an addictive
personality so I knew I had to stay away
as a kid and otherwise I would have
never have done anything
um so my experience with grand tourism
will come into this I mean
all of us doing the entire time is
practicing a couple of months before
with these the PlayStations sent a set
to my house and it was just repetition
repetition repetition I had this
unbelievable coach David Pearl who whose
story kind of mimician he started on GT
on the on the console and now he's an
unbelievable driver drives for yeah it's
like a division of Ferrari yeah and um
and he's unbelievable and um and it was
just practice practice I spent there'd
be moments where I was like at it for
hours like kind of because all it is is
repetition learning Apex entry learning
like the breasts of that the the breaks
like feeling how hard everything is
feeling like feeling the tracks I'll be
doing it for hours and then I'd be like
maybe I should stop and then I go oh I
don't work this is work I can do I can
do this and I just go again for a couple
hours so it was it was I mean it was
amazing to start leaning into that
because I just wasn't allowed as a kid
um so I actually got the job it was like
not into video games hate cars
again it makes it even better I think
I'm six foot five I'm six foot five it
was like everything tells you how
perfect I'll tell you what's perfect
about him he's got the biggest heart and
the emotion and that is what defines
this movie yeah and it's and as well as
good looking but it's that's what really
shines through this is a you know it's
about cars it's about racing but it's
also about heart and inspiration and
dreams coming true for anyone and I
think Archie embodies that that's the
energy he brings that's why he got a job
thank you very much
uh Orlando should bring it to you
because you mentioned him the executive
that your role is based off of I think
that is probably some of the best fan
casting that he could have probably done
is that not true
he was on set one day and it was it was
like yeah this is pretty good for me
what's up
but did you get to spend a lot of time
with him and what was the I know it's
not exactly a replication but what was
the essence of him that you wanted to
make sure you got folks to understand
because he really sort of was a mad
scientist yeah he was a dream he was a
dreamer in his own way I mean he was
really a mad wizard about it he kind of
had this he's got this sort of
insatiable appetite for life but also
this like dog with a bone attitude
towards getting something done
um he's um and he's he's he's super
passionate and and he was he had a he
has and remains he has a remarkable
relationship with Yan
um they really supported each other and
he really supported you and Through the
Years and and and to this day still does
he
um but he had this vision and I just saw
and and I said to Neil I think like
unlike anything else I'm just gonna play
Pure Passion you know just like because
who doesn't you know get off on passion
and just real adoration for the world
that he's in because he's got that
insatiable appetite for life but also
for the game and but not for the for the
world that he was building out and the I
think the idea that that would even be
possible for him is sort of like crazy
in itself and it speaks the way that he
thinks outside of the box but this whole
movie is about out being outside living
outside of the box inside the box of the
car but Outside the Box in terms of what
you think you can do and how you would
do it and how you'd execute and he
he so so that's what we we sort of we
kind of landed on at the end of the day
didn't we and we were like for sure I
love that um Jerry I didn't have to
maybe give the last word to you as a
girl birth boy in the 1980s I've
idolized you forever so I'm gonna have
to give you this great last word uh I
will say this the heart of this movie is
the family and playing the mother figure
I know there's women on the sidelines of
this sport that you were really
emulating yourself including being one
of them yeah what did you want audiences
to understand about that because you're
right it's not just putting the guy in
the car there's a there's a real family
and Team part of all of this yeah and
there's so many elements to it I think
this is a movie about growing up it's
about family it's about friendship and
encouraging each other but then
sometimes as parents we project our own
fears onto our kids you want them to
grow up and shine but also you're you're
scared you don't want to make the same
mistakes as you and I think that's all
injected in there just to give it like
it grounds it to say you know we love
each other but actually I'm frightened
like we all are you know and also there
was a true family it was a true it came
from a place of realism you feel the
anger you know how families can get a
little bit you feel that as well within
it well thank you so much for bringing
that oh it was a pleasure I'm telling
you these guys are amazing and so
talented
so I think I think that the whole family
will get something out of it you know
whether you're a gamer whether you love
cars whether you love friendships you
know this man is absolute Talent no he
is so I think she's definitely yeah
Simon who's song He's you know nominated
for an Academy Award you know Dad of
this that everyone every father will
identify with I love this okay we can't
tease them anymore I want to thank all
of you and thank all of you for watching
thank you